welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and we finally have
our first look at the bat bike it's been
a crazy time to be a bat man recently
and the first looks and leaks in the
movie are coming thick and fast giving
us more and more of an idea on what the
film will be about we finally got a
chance to see the bat bike as it hits
the streets of Glasgow this week and
there's a lot to unpack from this first
look throughout this video we'll be
giving our thoughts on it where it pulls
from and what could be happening in the
movie there's also a lot of leaked
sepharose I want to discuss and what
they mean there may be some spoilers
here so if you want to go into the film
as blind as possible then I highly
suggest that you turn off now make sure
you subscribe to the channel to never
miss a video
and without the way let's get into our
breakdown of all the information that we
have on the Batman okay so if you've
been keeping up to date with the channel
then you'll know that recently we
dropped a filming schedule that had
dates and times of a car chase scene
that will be taking place on the streets
of Glasgow this was initially thought to
be for the Batmobile and whilst this
could still be the case as of the making
of this video it does look like the road
scenes will be centered around the bat
bike the first pictures of Robert
Pattinson is Bruce Wayne featured the
character on top of a bike and it looks
like this may be the main mode of
transport for the Caped Crusader as we
know from information on the film that
he is just starting out the movie will
be a year two story so it does make
sense that he wouldn't have all of his
equipment together and this is why the
suit looks handmade and why is resorting
to a bike as for the bike itself it
looks extremely high-tech and you will
be surprised to see that it does come in
black at the front we can see what looks
to be ears almost similar to the cowl
itself and there is a pointy design to
the front of the ride designer ash
Thorpe over the last couple of months
has been teasing several details on his
design for the car so I was actually
very surprised to see this today we have
been expecting a Batmobile all week and
whilst it's not out of the question as
the scenes are filming over the weekend
it looks for the moment that they are
predominantly using a bike in the film
because of the scheduling I was sure
that the Batmobile would be posted by
Matt Reeves last night however the fact
that he didn't put anything out coupled
these shots makes a lot more sense so
yeah Batman will be using a motorbike at
some points throughout the film to get
around we may even get a Batpod ejection
scene from the Batmobile like the Dark
Knight and of course Batman Returns
that's purely speculation but I think
that it's more likely that it will have
the bike first before moving onto a car
there are rumors that there's going to
be a second Batsuit in the movie and who
knows he may upgrade his suit along with
the ride bikes have had a large part in
Batman's rich history and the most
recent one that springs to mind comes
from zero yeah in which Batman uses an
almost steampunk like version of the
ride to get around a Gotham that had
been completely taken over by the
Riddler the Riddler is of course going
to be the villain in this movie so it
does tease that they may be pulling from
that graphic novel Batman the Animated
Series also heavily featured motorbikes
and the bat helmet which the character
used to Don before riding off into the
night remember kids safety first
though he is more famously known for the
car this definitely isn't outside of
what the character tends to ride on
especially with some of the leaked
images that we have on the film so far
after visiting the murder scene that we
saw a couple of months ago perhaps
Batman decides that he needs to upgrade
his motorbike and this continues the
motif of escalation throughout the film
as for the car itself we don't have
anything beyond the information that it
will be a muscle or sports car that is
more grounded than what we've come to
see in Prior movies on screen right now
we have some of the concept cars that
Ash Thorpe is pulling from and after
looking at the bike they definitely line
up with the direction of the film and do
provide this photo with a lot more
weight on how the props in vehicles will
look overall it does feel like they've
looked at things that you can currently
buy and this makes me believe that the
1990s Times saying that the movie is
supposed to have maybe incorrect
we did see from the leaked footage of
the mugging that there was a mobile
phone there so personally I don't
believe that this is still a period
piece the bike definitely seems to fit
in with that as it's very sleek but it
also seems like something you could
potentially buy again this Batman is
going to be very grounded and rather
than just getting crazy gadgets he will
be reappropriation things from the real
world and turning them into his arsenal
I think the bike looks great and though
I was hoping for a bit more
today's shoot I'm definitely hype for
the look now of course if the Batmobile
drops I'll cover it but if this is all
we get then consider me happy with the
first look now moving away from this we
finally have confirmation of what color
the Batsuit will be the Batsuit video
had a red filter of the top of it so it
was very difficult to tell what color it
actually was and this led to a lot of
speculation this image dropped recently
showing the suit and behind it you can
also see a black piece of cloth as well
as a bright blue one so though we know
that the suit is definitely a specific
color the cape is still up in the air I
am kind of hoping for a gray and blue
suit and there were even rumors of that
but I guess we will have to see as I
mentioned earlier there are also leaks
that there will be a second suit in the
film after the first bad suit is
destroyed so these two capes
it could be mix and match anyway I put
together an image of the suit and the
camera test side-by-side so you can see
that everything lines up and this leak
is indeed true the person who took this
photo also posted an image of a
moviemakers van which is a production
company that specializes in film Captain
Obvious year though there have been some
people saying this is fake I don't know
why someone would go to the lengths of
making a fake suit just to get a couple
of likes on Twitter Instagram user
fellowship of the corns also took this
photo for Gotham renewal corporation
this looks like it could be a Wayne
Enterprise subsidiary that specializes
in revitalizing dilapidated parts of
Gotham
there are several images on their
Instagram page in which they stand
beside the sign and this adds a lot of
authenticity to them and also allows us
to date when they were taken the board
was apparently found near hardwood
mental hospital and according to the
user the film crew was there at one
point
taking principal photography now I don't
know about you but this just screams
Arkham Asylum to me not only was it a
mental hospital but it also has that
classic gothic feel to it that makes it
look like the location would be right at
home in the Batman universe Arkham has
always been somewhere that's built to
help those with severe mental problems
but you often get the feeling that it
could be making things worse this horror
aesthetic often backs that up in the
books and has always been a more
sinister side to it I feel like these
images definitely capture that and it's
amazing seeing what could be Arkham in
this pose
it also shows that Bruce could be
revitalizing the building as no doubt he
will be filling it with a lot of
residents soon now before we get in hit
the rest of the video I just want to let
you know we're giving away a free copy
of the infinity Saga box set to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be in with a chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the updates in
the comments section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
March in the cell be shipped out from
the intro ever gets the prize so best of
luck to everyone who takes part okay and
finally we have a look at the Halloween
setting for the movie if you've been
keeping up to date with the channel then
you'll know that we posted a story about
a casting call at a Halloween party
earlier in the week this was given a lot
more way with the release of some
pumpkins and what looks to be a GCPD
officer walking down some steps for
those who don't know the film is based
on the graphic novel on Halloween and
these are providing a lot of way to the
theory that there will be a big moment
that happens on the infamous holiday the
long Halloween follows several murders
that all occur over certain holidays and
they spring forth from this date because
that is when the story really starts to
kick off though it initially begins in
June our wedding it's from Halloween
onwards that it gets a full thrust and
really puts Gotham into a panic though
this is a little shot it does show the
kind of architecture that the film is
going for and I love how the building
has an almost classic feel to it that
reminds me a lot of Batman 1999 I can't
wait to see scenes like this emotion and
it has me all very excited and that's
everything since the last update and
yeah like I said I'm just very hyped for
the movie I think it all looks really
good and I love the down-to-earth feel
that this film has everything so far
seems very grounded and it's brilliant
watching the little tidbits of
information come out bit by bit we do
breakdowns on the Batman every week same
bat-time same bat-channel so make sure
you stay locked into heavy spoilers to
never miss any of the information you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and check out our full
breakdown of the reportedly leaked
second Batsuit which is gonna be linked
at the end you want to support the
channel from is lit this 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you get access to content early
and can also suggest video topics and
breakdowns you massively appreciate it
and it goes a long way to helping videos
I just get made you want to come chat to
us after the show either follow us at
Definition whitey
or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best not see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]